[Music]
you get your hair done you can't be
touched
you're just you're on point for at least
48 hours the queer community needs a
safe space to get haircuts and that's
part of the reason why I'm here
my name is des Marshall I'm a barber I
work in Brooklyn New York
the barber shop I work at is called the
gamesman it's kind of an institution
here in downtown Brooklyn the owner
Frank has been here for over 50 years
the clientele has been a lot of men who
working in the neighborhood it's a lot
of lawyers a lot of judges other types
of businessmen I kind of throw a wrench
in so off of it I mix it up a little bit
my clientele is mostly queer trans
gender non-conforming folks of color non
folks of color for the most part my
clientele is the LGBTQ community I think
with barbershops it's difficult as a
woman to walk in the can sometimes to
feel like a boys club it's nice to feel
like you can let your hair down before
get it off
I think I'm building a bridge in
different ways can you be at 5:00 3:30 I
got you for queer folks for trans folks
are gender non-conforming folks hair is
very important you keep it really crisp
or more rounded got you you need a
barber that you feel comfortable to talk
to about how you want to look what's
that vision that you have someone who
can execute it but also do it in a way
that they're not going to be judging you
throughout the whole process
get up I get to spend my day with other
queer folks in a space that you know 20
years ago we probably couldn't even walk
walked into you know I'm part of that
story now my clients are part of that
story now we're part of the history of
this place we're part of its legacy and
that's it's really cool
[Music]
[Music]